à l'assemblée nationale la salle des
quatre colonnes est en effervescence
une semaine après l'école les députés
font leur rentrée plus tôt que prévu une
reprise plutôt tendue dans laquelle un
nouveau député comme françois de
mazières député maire de versailles
pourrait se sentir perdus au milieu des
rouages parlementaire on a très vite ses
repères vous savez d'abord il se trouve
que je ne suis pas mon propre parcours
parce que j'ai été
sous préfet j'ai été membre de cabinet
ministériel il se trouve que je connais
le fonctionnement du parlement
donc quand vous arrivez vous êtes bord
très bien accueilli et vous avez très
rapidement les repères nécessaires
fait rare pour un nouveau député
françois de mazières pose une question
au gouvernement sur le dossier brûlant
de la loi sru
dès sa première séance officielle une
multiplication par 5 des sanctions
entraîneraient 4 dérive
la première c'est le poids
disproportionné des sanctions élu aux
dernières élections législatives le
député-maire yves binois sans étiquette
apparenté ump débute sa carrière au sein
de l'opposition
et il assure que ses deux mandats sont
compatibles
c'est pas du tout compliqué quand vous
êtes proche de paris comment voyager 1
chance d'être à 20 minutes entre les
deux bureaux etc non seulement pas
compliqué mais c'est vraiment utile
c'est que les interventions que je peux
faire sans nuri de l'expérience de
terrain
cette double étiquette se fera
probablement au projet de loi sur le
non-cumul des mandats voulue par le
président hollande
en attendant françois de mazières
partage son temps entre l'assemblée et
sa commune de versailles